t-series I challenged you to a battle to
the death why have you not accepted my
challenge are you scared
t-series cuz I'm not you think you can
beat me in subscribers ah maybe you can
but you cannot beat me IRL man up and
accept my challenge t-series until then
smash subscribe smash subscribe that
being said I had a completely original
idea for a video today twitch perfect
time moments you seen these videos you
heard about this hilarious okay
it's basically streamers they said all
day and all night playing video games
what a bunch of losers and then
eventually something funny happens
because not because they they themselves
are entertaining coming from me it's the
kind of thing you don't really like but
it's kind of thing you just go funny so
let's react to that today everybody
I'm the hype man everybody I know how to
make stuff interesting they'll destroy
you Marcus
you gotta go you gotta go yeah go yes
Detroit become human the PlayStation for
heard the call alright I'm out there was
there was there some in here that like
like obviously we want but like it seems
like I just realized this is me watching
Nova watching some other guy watching
Miley Cyrus 2018 everybody everybody
else enjoys them so I guess they just
they would run with the narrative that
you know that everybody everybody
enjoyed it instead of keeping us in
there to be like this videos in Shh
[Laughter]
that's good that's a wholesome funny
play see how dare you question the
integrity of the fine brothers Nova
disgusting can't believe anyone would do
that these speculations with no grounds
on them all right you know what this is
actually pretty fun I'm actually doing
what is this guy creeping as well he
lives I figured out why he was creeping
nothing hey how about that a funny video
that was funny she shoots and he gets up
he's saved she saved his life
you know what maybe I was a little harsh
these are actually quite enjoyable let's
keep watching smash like if you enjoyed
this video right now saying how nice the
cars were as also a look at this kid
Stan this bicycle kids don't do now
that's a sandwich nine-year-old right
there you decided on your own to follow
me you are incorrect sir kill ya
that's unreal that was perfect timing
though I got a bit wait I gotta say it
again sir Kelly yeah you decided on your
own that's unreal
I feel like the people that watch these
streams they know what the trigger is
and they'll use it at the perfect time
that's kind of sad
though impressive but in the two hundred
years they didn't like neither of them
fell off the pier until that's funny
actually I thought that we're glued or
something you can buy cough syrup with
other without what do you call it we
call it blue see you that was such
perfect moment such relatable awesome
sauce everybody it's much like if you
thought that was that bad guys and I
wanted six okay Rankin's reaction is so
again look at have no idea what's going
on I feel so old watching this what all
these kids video games that they're
playing I never seen them I don't play
games I just react to other people
playing games
what what's so weird about that Mommy BL
okay
I never leaves the most Swedish sounding
person ever I don't know how he still
has that act of it it sounds like me
went back in 2012 or something that
timing was oh that is my donation sound
I can't even do it what happened to me
huh what happened to me remember who I
used to be why are we still here why am
i singing what's it gonna be oh my god
people are just dying left and right
I like that I like that cuz it wasn't
perfect timing it was just enough for
you to go what nany that was good I like
that I like that it's much like if we
made your leg this is obviously funny
though like a having a good laugh hey
it's another another Swedish yes again
apparently this is all Swedish people do
we just play games all day oh really
again ome ga
Viji Lu hello Remy GA Lu Elmo just died
again
what the hell again ome Gao give me a
motivational speech thanks brother
you can thank me later ok sorry it was
that was awesome he was always like the
game heard him I thought you got ran
over by a car
replaced pubsey still pathetic how do
you run over my car there ok that was
good
ok that was good got me first the worst
thing to say in a marriage proposal
[ __ ] up no one cares about your robot
[ __ ] why why did you leave us
I just want him to come back for one
video just one video please just for a
little time sake please 2016 me too
before the bubble had burst I remember
talking to it about Brad like how old
he's edgy content on YouTube was just
everywhere and it was a bubble which is
waiting to burst now maybe I was the
needle in that thing but I didn't I
didn't make the bubble okay
all right get some epic music
[Music]
the DJ's perfect timing cell I play that
game you play you spend so much time
doing nothing and then just something
happens out of nowhere I get why he got
so scared but also wouldn't I be salutes
oi boy ad ad ad TV channel who gets
scared of playing video reaction it
looks like himself as well that's enough
perfect time moments for me for one day
that's pretty funny shout-out to
everyone for letting the user of clips
I'm sorry if I roasted you go man I sang
yeah I will link everyone in the
description if you want to check them
out support support each other on
different platforms money brad has a
perfect time brad boat oh I can't shout
out everyone else and not Brad this is
the most popular Harley ok and now for
my feature film birds with the invention
of the mobile phone nobody's ever seen a
bird but I move to show you an inside
look at nature's flying feathery fur
balls nobody over there and nobody over
here Oh home alone and there's a guy
filming us oh really yeah right there oh
oh I'm looking right at him whoa why is
he coming up I don't know Brad believe
we need a brad the birds too please
[Music]
that's Brad bow to everybody thank you
very much for watching see you guys
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]